juin 2015 nous sommes dans une ville
industrielle dans le nord de l'italie
nous avons la permission de rencontrer
en prison un des rares partis de la
mafia calabraise
il en sait beaucoup sur les liens entre
son pays et le canada
rencontrer un mafieux dans une prison à
sécurité maximale comporte son lot de
problèmes bureaucratiques même avec tous
les documents réglementaires
[Musique]
après deux heures d'attentes on peut en
faire rencontrer celui pour qui on a
fait le voyage
à
[Musique]
ce prisonnier s'appelle giuseppe costa
nous devons cacher son visage puisqu'il
est devenu délateur la justice italienne
le protège car ils continuent de
témoigner contre ses anciens complices
en prison ceux qui jouent un rôle
important finissent toujours par avoir
des nouvelles avant de vous expliquer le
parcours de cet homme et les raisons qui
l'ont amené à devenir délateur faisons
un saut en arrière de l'italie au canada
nous voici à toronto plus précisément
dans la banlieue de temps à nyon
26 juin 1991 en fin d'après midi
geovanni costa rentrait chez lui une
auto blanche s'est approché lentement
un homme s'est penché hors de la voiture
des témoins ont d'abord cru qu'il
s'agissait d'un accident de la route
loto de costa a perdu le contrôle et a
roulé une centaine de mètres avant de
s'immobiliser contre un arbre giovanni
costa a été atteint d'un projectile
il est mort sur le coup son meurtre a
défrayé la manchette jusqu'en italie
giovanni costa 38 ans père de trois
enfants était un immigrant italien qui
menait une vie sans histoire
on ne lui connaît aucun lien avec le
monde criminel
dégoûté par les activités mafieuses de
ses frères il s'est installé au canada
loin d'eux pour protéger sa famille
ce qui nous ramène ici en italie dans
cette prison à sécurité maximale de
prisonniers giuseppe costa et le frère
de giovani assassiné en 1991
arrive le sieur pendant ma détention en
prison j'ai compris les erreurs que j'ai
commises
ma femme venait toujours me voir à
chaque mois oui elle me souriait mais je
voyais qu'elle était triste triste et
déjà mais même la prison ça n'apporte
rien
[Musique]
giuseppe costa était le chef mafieux de
cybernautes en calade
la famille mafieuse de toronto
proviennent de cette ville mais en 1990
les choses ont mal tourné pour costa
une guerre sanglante éclate entre son
clan et le clan rival celui de la
famille comisso quatre de ses frères
sont assassinés y compris son frère
vincenzo qui était sourd et muet quand
les commissions ont tué vincenzo ontv
piovani c'est ça devait être un coup
terrible pour vous celui qui était sur
mu était à vélo il travaillait comme
concierge dans une école et ils l'ont
abattu comme s'il s'agissait d'un boss
c'est ça la cruauté de la n'dranghetta
le fait qu'il ne faisait pas partie de
la haine drame guetta ne les intéressait
pas kg chacun des meurtres a été d'une
rare violence et costa s'est vengé de
façon tout aussi brutale
cinquante personnes ont été abattues ou
victimes de violentes agressions mais la
vengeance a fini par rattraper giuseppe
costa
il lui a coûté sa liberté je suis
condamné à la prison à vie pour les
homicides lors de la guerre au sein de
la n'dranghetta la sentence que j'ai
reçue était pour dix meurtres et 14
tentatives de meurtre
la n'dranghetta c'est une entrée sans
sortie ce n'est que de la noirceur
il est récemment devenu repentis et
témoigne contre ses anciens frères
d'armes
c'est très rare dans l'aisne dring état
parce que ses membres sont liés par le
sang
les liens de parenté assure une omerta
encore plus grande que celle de la mafia
sicilienne
ce silence rend encore plus difficile le
travail des procureurs comme m antonio
de bernardo qui se consacre à la lutte
contre la mafia
l'utilisation de repentis c'est aussi
utile pour votre travail à vous donc de
globe et c'est ce compte destiné à se
plaindre guetta calabraise est différent
des autres organisations mafieuses qui
se trouvent dans les autres régions
d'italie notamment par le fait qu'elle
est très fermé les membres de
l'organisation sont souvent tissé par
des liens familiaux où existe un sens
profond de l'omerta c'est une forte
censure de l'omerta cui série musicale à
broadway league à l'abri et c'est ce qui
fait en sorte que les collaborateurs
sont peu nombreux et plus précieux ce
comparé à d'autres groupes criminels les
spectres d'al qatta criminale outre les
délateurs
l'autre façon d'ébranler les mafieux
c'est de confisquer leur argent
l'italie a créé il de ce quad spécial la
guardia des finances za où la police
financière pour contrer les crimes
économiques
will i am vinci et le commandant dans la
région de siderno pour cette escouade
c'est lui qui suit l'argent et les
profits du crime dans la région
il a comme cette maison luxueuse saisie
en 2014 lors d'une importante opération
anti mafieuses elle a été construite
pour permettre aux bandits de se
rencontrer discrètement combien ça vaut
pour pour pour l'état parce
qu'éventuellement ce sera confisquée 3
millions d'euros tout ce qui a été
confisqué lors de l'opération va signer
là est évalué selon une estimation
prudente à 3 millions d'euros non son
statisme et bien sûr sainthorant que
sochaux on a aussi confisqué des
compagnies parce que certains des
suspects possédé et géré des sociétés
qui offrait des services en particulier
des compagnies publicitaires
est ce que tout ça a un lien avec les
cas nada sur lausanne
c'est absolument oui ils sont en contact
permanent avec le canada et illusions
certainement des intérêts ce que la
droite a produit ici est très
probablement réinvestis au canada c'est
ce qui apparaît dans les rapports dans
quel au fil des générations les mêmes
familles domine il est lié entre
l'italie et le canada se resserre
par exemple l'assassin de giovanni costa
en 1991
c'est cet homme ricardo rumbo il a fait
le trajet de siderno à toronto exprès
pour l'éliminer en 1993 il a été
condamné à 30 ans de prison en italie
pour se meurt
mais l'an dernier lors d'une opération
policière visant un réseau mafieux de
prêts usuraires à siderno le nom de
rombeau est réapparu santoro mot chéri e
des suspects est le neveu de route bout
on l'a arrêté quelques heures avant son
retour au canada ils aient été établies
au canada il nous l'avons arrêté
exactement six heures avant qu'il y
retourne il était revenu ici seulement
pour la période estivale mais il vivait
depuis plus d'un an et demi au canada il
ya une osmose entre les gens qui partent
pour le canada et ceux qui reviennent le
canada exerce un grand pouvoir
d'attraction sur les calabrais depuis
des décennies dès la fin des années 60
giuseppe costa voulait lui aussi s'y
installer touristes a légèrement et à
l'époque on y est allés comme touristes
mais mon intention était de m'installer
là-bas j'ai travaillé dans une
boulangerie show la rue dundas à toronto
non mais c'est normal que je ne suis pas
resté parce que ma famille avait besoin
de moi mes frères étant plus jeune je
pensais pouvoir reprendre mon travail
d'imprimeur mais ça ne s'est pas passé
ainsi
je me suis engagé sur la voie de la
criminalité de la n'dranghetta comme
jade c'est comme ça que mon ascension a
commencé c'est grâce aux confidences des
délateurs que les autorités peuvent
percer le secret de l'organisation en
quoi cet important de comprendre ce qui
se passe ailleurs ce qui a lieu ailleurs
comment ça fonctionne au canada à bord
ont provoqué apicale on a compris qu au
niveau du leadership l'organisation de
la n'dranghetta est unique est unique au
monde
d'où l'importance de savoir ce qui se
passe au canada en allemagne en
australie et ailleurs
il possède le même système et les mêmes
règles ils sont gouvernés par les mêmes
hommes dans le monde entier alors pour
eux parler de sydney où parler de
toronto c'est essentiellement la même
chose
500 c'est ça quand ça
pour mieux comprendre la haine bringue
état il faut aller à la recherche de ses
origines
c'est dans ces petits villages à flanc
de montagne que la mafia calabraise
trouve sa force c'est à partir
d'endroits comme celui ci que les chefs
de clan gère leurs activités criminelles
l'aem dring états contrôlent une bonne
partie du commerce mondial de la cocaïne
et brassent des milliards de dollars
nous nous trouvons dans le village de
platine avec le journaliste italien
alberto n'est pas digne
qu'est ce que tu peux me dire sur ce
village sin or platine ce village là
c'est vraiment le synonyme d'un drain
guetta c'est un village de 2000 wissant
3000 habitants
il ya des familles très fort très
important pour la mafia est très peur
c'est très pauvre
n'hésitez pas mais les gens ici tu
avoues ne travaille pas puis il ya les
animaux il y à il ya de la terre mais
mais il ya quelque chose d'autre il ya
un économique on voit pas qu'c'est
l'économie sûrement mafieuses les gens
ici ne partent pas ne partant
jamais
et elle est allée intéressant pour oui
ça fait mal et n'y avait pas une auto
aussi le maintenant il y en a des tonnes
les mafieux gèrent leurs affaires à
l'abri des regards
et quand ils sont recherchés ils se
cachent souvent dans des lieux assez
inusité à la fin du mois de janvier
la police a surpris deux chefs de clan
de la 'ndrangheta dans un bunker situé à
une heure de route de platine ça faisait
dix ans que les deux mafieux puyet la
justice il contrôler leurs activités
criminelles du fond de cette cache et
ils ne sont pas seuls dans le village
même de platine il existait d'autres
endroits pour se cacher alberto on voit
ici vraiment un trou dans le mur et
c'est un baquet qu'ils avaient été
retrouvées ce fait ça fait un an c est
récent c'était bien grosse truie parce
qu'il avait tu peux voir ja hirai ici
mais il y a
un pièce de du mur qui bougeait eh oui
c'est incroyable c'est vraiment une
pièce cérémonie dans une chambre c'est
fait pour y vivre et y à de l'eau de
l'électricité
il ya la madone et on peut se cacher ici
longtemps dans un bâtiment abandonné
tout près du premier un autre bonne
corde à huy
voilà c'est tout cas c'est bien là bas
il admis ah oui c'est plus grand que les
autres si grave maintenant et ça c'est
important mosquée parce que ici ils ont
trouvé le mafieux ok le voir même sur
internet ici
c'était le 2010le février 2010 j'ai
trouvé ça vers yocream uni qui est le
chef de l etat fuji tv et s est caché
pour saison il se cache
car les enjeux sont importants et l'état
italien
durement touché par la crise financière
a une motivation supplémentaire pour
s'attaquer à la mafia fois tous les six
ont procédé à la saisie de tous les
biens appartenant aux membres de la
n'dranghetta je suis certain que la
dette du gouvernement italien
n'existerait plus
l'argent c'est le nerf de la guerre
contre le crime organisé pour
déstabiliser les criminels
les autorités doivent s'attaquer à leur
fortune l'italie s'est dotée de loi
musclée permettant les saisies et ce qui
a été confisqué et souvent réutilisés
contre le crime organisé mercedes la jma
rabe laoudi à pujaut et sookie et vous
les utilisez toutes les journaux si tous
les jours tout c'est formidable
ça c'est la vôtre
loto de fonction du colonel napolitano
appartenait aussi un criminel donc vous
changer de voiture souvent assez ça vous
avez un choix c'est un grand choix modo
force c'était un crédit d verra
maintenant le seul moyen d'attaqué
réellement la haine prend qatar et de
s'attaquer à ces avoirs ou des 20 qu'il
faille dire quizy les liens autour est
tout c'est aussi une question symbolique
le fait que la police se promène avec
une auto d'une valeur de 100 mille euros
appartenant à une famille mafieuse
c'est un symbole que l'état brivot sur
la n20 gaza et simoneau de loustallot 17
ans drague
ce sont de petites victoires dans une
guerre qui semble sans fin lors de notre
passage en calabre la police financière
nous donne rendez vous dans un lieu
secret il est minuit
c'est le début d'une opération policière
d'envergure et ce sur la cible une
organisation à la tête d'un vaste réseau
d'importation de stupéfiants qui s'étend
sur trois continents la police italienne
a déclaré avoir saisi quatre tonnes de
cocaïne lors d'une opération récente
valeur un milliard et demi de dollars du
même coup la police soutient que quatre
tonnes c'est à peu près ce que la
n'dranghetta importe chaque mois en
europe ce qui lui donne une capacité
financière quasi inépuisable
nous arrivons en force dans le village
de centre de feignants aspromonte et
il est deux heures du matin curieusement
malgré tout le bruit que font les
policiers
personne ne se montre personne ne jette
un oeil à la fenêtre pour voir ce qui se
passe le suspect visé n'est pas chez lui
les policiers font le tour du village et
ne trouve aucun des suspects recherchés
mais dans la ville portuaire de zhaotong
euros tout près la police a plus de
chance
un individu est appréhendé en tout
trente huit personnes ont été arrêtées
lors de cette opération
la pieuvre mafieuses en constante
évolution n'est pas facile à déjouer
wall and tan montagne de voir il ya 40
ou 50 ans nous étions des voleurs de
bétail
maintenant ça n'existe plus à la place
il y à la drogue d'extorsion l'usure ça
prend une personne propres pour le faire
quelqu'un qui sait utiliser un
ordinateur qui parle d'un minimum de
trois langues qui possède une solide
culture c'est comme ça que la ndrangheta
est en train de changer
parmi ses succès contre le crime
organisé maître de bernardo a fait
condamner giuseppe bruins et de thunder
bay en ontario à 9 ans et demi de prison
pour association mafieuse que les
besoins sont tantôt groupe pour fédérer
n'est pas simplement un groupe qui
commet des crimes fini c'est un groupe
qui finit par prendre le pouvoir pour
décider où un état peut décider du sort
d'une communauté tout entière
l'influencé l'économie et de décider par
exemple des candidatures lors des
élections politiques mettent la gare
aussi bien pour les calabrais
le canada a toujours été comme leur
deuxième maison mais c'est une maison
qui est payant pour celui qui est dans
la langue et à au canada c'est comme
s'il était chez lui il bouge il se
déplace il fait ses affaires
de sa cellule en italie giuseppe costa a
entendu les échos du conflit entre les
clans mafieux du canada ces dernières
années la guerre qui a mené à la chute
des résultats et permis une remontée des
clan de la 'ndrangheta de toronto il fut
un temps où c'était la mafia sicilienne
qui menait au canada maintenant selene
drame d'état qui a pris le pouvoir
internet est éloquent quels sont ceux
qui sont au canada doivent toujours
répondre à la maison mère qui est en
calabre la calandre même mais ça ne met
pas les clans de la région de toronto à
l'abri de la violence typiquement
mafieuse trois meurtres ont secoué les
banlieues de toronto en moins de trois
ans guerres de clans aux tensions avec
les familles dirigeantes de montréal
impossible de le confirmer mais les
crimes portait la signature de la mafia
le dernier est survenu à la fin janvier
un patriarche de la n'dranghetta rocco
zito 87 ans a été tué par son beau fils
après une vie au coeur d'alêne dring et
à giuseppe costa livre ce message aux
jeunes tentés par le monde faussement
séduisant du crime organisé
je dis aux jeunes de ne pas se laisser
influencer par tous les beaux discours
de gens qui essaient de les séduire
verlaine granby
ça ne mène nulle part une autre porte et
malgré tout ce qu'il a perdu dans les
guerres sanglantes et toutes les années
en prison josé costa continue de nourrir
un rêve de guerre mondiale quand même en
avons fini avec la justice
c'est un voyage au ghana
[Musique]